i want to start by saying i've seen the
first six episodes of the series
and i'm all [ __ ] in on this
oh my god how come you've seen so many
steve they said
they sent me six and that's basically
like for the people that will be
watching this interview
that's the easiest way to describe or to
tell people how good the series is is
that
you know i could have stopped after two
but i was like i need to know more
oh man oh yes mate
it's real good um thank you
i want to stress that so i guess my the
most important question i have for you
guys
is were you allowed to eat on set
because you have
costumes that basically are you know
they they leave nothing
for uh you know it's very interesting
costumes
yeah short answer no no yeah not really
no i mean yeah
it was it was a definite i mean like
you're always thinking about it right
and like you're always thinking like oh
everyone
people can people can people can see me
they can
see me and this is like a real real
challenge that way
seeing everyone eating like chocolate
cake and you're thinking if only
if only yeah right but i i was eating so
much because we had to work out so much
yeah i mean i remember one of the first
meetings and there was a picture of us
in suits and ridley kind of
drew on muscles on my arms and he was
like that
yeah that looks good okay
time to work out i actually want to
specifically talk about ridley what um
he's such a brilliant filmmaker and one
of the things i've heard about
from people that have worked with him is
that he works incredibly fast
oh my god oh yeah i mean yeah to the
point where like i remember
uh i think i just i just got to pee
because we had to take the suit off and
it was all this sort of thing then
putting it back on and all i remember
hearing like over someone's radio was
like
and we're rolling and i'm thinking to
myself my stunt guy
is in my place right now thinking that
they're literally going to be you know
filming him while
while we're going and it's like i'm
running running and there's an action
and we're gone
and it's like we're moving on we do the
scene it's like two takes and then we
move on to the next thing and it's like
it's like it's like a storm and yeah i
mean many times me and amanda were like
that was the worst acting i've ever done
in my life
but it's written me being like like i
didn't even speak english in this one
and really was just like yeah that's
fine that's
not yep we got it yeah it was yeah it
was insane
how much did aaron tell you once you
landed the role
how much did he explain about the full
arc of your characters
and how much was he sort of like script
by script you were finding things out
he gave us nothing uh he literally was
you know what i mean he like he like
appeared gave us a script and then
disappeared
and we were like oh my god like vultures
to a story like literally just trying to
find what we can and
yeah it was it was very rare to get any
information out of that man
even though he there was 101 things
going in his mind
but he's such a genius and the way that
the story goes you were like
you can imagine getting getting the
scripts of five and six while you're
shooting and you're like
oh my what is happening
you know that was so exciting
one of the things i also commend about
the show is that each episode sort of
pulls back a little bit on the onion if
you will
you keep on learning new things and it
keeps you invested because you're
constantly wanting to know what the f is
about to happen you know
what was it like for you guys you know
on set reading these scripts for the
first time
uh i want to so talk about spoilers but
i can't
yeah it was exciting because again it's
it really one you're you're learning
about the world that you're in but also
to your your you're learning a bit more
about the
characters that you're playing and i
think that was what was really
that's what really drove us to read more
of what was going on i think
yeah many a time i'd be going to a man
and being like have you seen what you do
here
isn't that inside isn't that crazy and
you know what i mean and it's like it's
just discovering new pits about
characters
what was it like doing these big
sequences on the show
i mean so much fun
just like come to work the first day and
there are
five stunt people welcoming you and be
like today we're gonna fly
that is like such a dream uh coming true
and the the whole crew and all the
people that we worked with were just
incredibly nice and supportive of
um what we were doing so that helped so
much as well
um to just let go and keep exploring
because that obviously can be
a fear trigger to not know what's going
on or
you want to kind of control your
character's arc or
be good at what you do or whatever but i
think it was
very very exciting and also helpful for
our characters just to
go with it and let happen whatever
happened and just let go in each episode
which i think also why the characters
ended up quite
weird and dynamic in a way
what i love about science fiction is it
can deal with modern
issues in a um futuristic setting so
you're not like being bashed over the
head
do you know what i mean you can really
sort of you can tackle a lot of stuff
and this show uh
embraces the religion and technology and
talking about these two issues can can
you guys share a little bit about that
yeah i think it was really um it's
exciting
when you're in a world in which even
though it is sci-fi
it is almost supplementary to the actual
issues and topics that it explores
uh you know it's you know the idea that
we are
exploring parenthood which is a
universal thing that everyone goes
through the
idea of faith and belief that's
something that everyone goes through
uh society and and and you know what it
means to
sort of be in this in start again is
is a is something that you can either
you know you can put in a in a world of
fantasy
put in the modern day or put in you know
something that is quite
sci-fi and futuristic futuristic and i
think that is
that was what was so brilliant about
aaron's writing and what is so brilliant
about this show and why it's so
it's so you know hooking is because it's
it's not just
relying on the sci-finess of it all it's
not relying on the jazzy effects
it's it's relying on human emotions or
ai emotions and that exploration and
like what it means to be
ai and feel and i think you know because
i'm a massive nerd and
i i you know i remember thinking you
know you can't you can't pull the wool
over my eyes like you can see you know
i've seen it all
can't shock me this show shocked me
because i've never seen anything like it
neither have i read anything like it you
know so it's it was
it's and again kudo you know that's to
aaron and that's to ridley's you know
visionary take and
again and that's to amanda's terrifying
acting skills
but uh you know so it's all part
i have no idea what i'm doing no you you
did a great job listen i have to rap i'm
just gonna say
congrats i cannot wait to finish the
series um
good luck with the rest of the speed
dating thanks steve thank you much
steve nice to meet you have a great day